more than seven years after being
convicted of murdering his girlfriend
Riva steenkamp paralympian Oscar
Pistorius based another verdict
this prison behind me is where he spent
a majority of his jail sentence it's
also where parole board members have
gathered to hear from him as to whether
he's been rehabilitated enough to walk
free
June Stephen Camp riva's mother was also
in the building and presented a
statement on how her daughter's murder
has impacted her
do you believe that Oscar's remorseful
no never
mind
or rehabilitated
the steam camps maintain that Oscar
hasn't rehabilitated until he admits he
intentionally killed their daughter
Oscar continues to testify that he
thought he was shooting at an intruder
in the bathroom
as a crowd of journalists gathered to
break the news of a decision the
spokesman for the Department of
Correctional Services talked us through
parole proceedings was given 13 years
and five months he has served the
minimum detention period
meaning he is eligible to be considered
for parole placement
building in the same spot
told us parole placement had been
rejected the
arrived at a particular decision which
was largely Guided by a lot of
clarification order from the Supreme
Court which stated that Mr Pistorius has
not yet the minimum detention period the
spokesman for the Department of
Correctional Services is currently
getting creamed by the media because
he's just reneged on the statement that
they've made so when will he actually
become eligible
um in August 2024
pistorius's attorney says they will
appeal the parole refusal
another appeal for parole rejected now
Oscar pastors will spend at least
another year Behind These Bars
riva's family lawyer told Sky News the
family welcomed the decision but do not
see this as a cause for celebration as
they continue to miss and mourn their
daughter
Sky News Pretoria